gründe sieht aus wie menschlicher holen
hätte wie sie in seine wohnung aus
mussten wir zum arzt gegangen leute
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
essen testen heute mit einem gas der
eine sehr spezielle aus walding
mitgebracht hat kommentierte picture
toni ist heute mit dabei leute und julie
thema was über deine essensgewohnheiten
es gibt ja sachen die wir heute nicht
geruht haben was gibt sachen die wir
nicht geholt haben fleisch isst kein
fleisch
was die sache wird kein falscher alle
die jetzt behaupten dass wir uns heute
wieder einen kinosaal zu in die fresse
presse dass sie die leute nicht aber wir
waren zum einkaufen haben eine sehr nice
aus walding aber ein
und ich würde sagen in alter manier
ziehe ich einfach irgendwie sagte wir
hoffen dass die sachen die du am meisten
hasst es ist ein bisschen mehr weil es
sind eigentlich sagen du machst die alle
und ich glaube dass jeder da draußen
eigentlich mag ich hasse diese leute ich
muss dazu bevor wir jetzt folgt die
erste lange ich kann nicht einfach so
sagen okay es ist eine sache die es
wirklich gefährlich eine sache die die
menschheit seit jahrhunderten nur in
extremfällen zu sich nimmt tausende
fälle sind dokumentiert wo menschen
davon gestorben sind sagt zu essen die
rede ist von tomaten aus tomaten schon
mein leben lang fragt meine mama mein
papa alles was dir ich weiß nicht warum
man tomaten sind ja eigentlich wie
gurken nur rote tomaten sind ja
eigentlich wie gurken nur rot bleibt und
ich kann mich wenn ihnen salat und so
ein bisschen ist wenn dies oft pizza
drauf sind so große scheiben runter aber
die tomatensoße gibt das ist ja auch von
der forschung bewiesen dass hat ganze
tomaten einfach höchst giftig sind
wo ist aber auch ein essen
doch eine tomate ist denn er ist ja
nicht überlebe leute ihr wisst ihr was
unschuldig ist nicht ganz da kann ich
die abreißen so klein so eine leckere
süße tomate klasse beschreibt wie ist
deine erfahrung müsste tomaten weiter
leute die nächste sache leute ich werde
jetzt nicht glauben
die größte möglichkeit als den fisch
gern machen
wir müssen diese waffe oder genau der
nächste schritt auf dem weg dazu dich zu
vergiften wie klasse oder das eine das
ein bisschen wenig kurzum deiner anfang
hatte ich würde halt schon mindestens
mal somit also eigentlich nur die
eigentlich habe ich doppelt so viel
ich kam von der spd
[Applaus]
doch dann macht man alles einmal mit
tasten masse wahlsystem essen schmeckt
der erste moment ist richtig widerlich
hattest du scheiße was zu essen
meine fresse 2000 jahre später heute an
der stelle muss ich euch leider
mitteilen dass wir vor fünf minuten show
die an einen allergischen manchmal
bergischen einfach ein lebensmittel
[Musik]
sterben ist treibt einem die tränen die
augen leute die dinge hier das kann man
keinem menschen zumuten so was zu essen
wir haben als nächstes sind nämlich
meine normalen chips sind salder weniger
and sword das heißt so viel wie abfüllt
wein essig und die mit meersalz genau
deshalb halten ach so ja bist du bereit
so auch immer halte auch die wegen ihrer
therapie der pont noch gar nichts
dazwischen aber noch nach chips die
riechen nicht so krass
das ist gar nicht so inspiriert die
nicht so intensives gibt so richtige die
so richtig intensiv nach essen riechen
und schmecken ist toll wieder licht
rücken sie aus
ich glaube nicht dass die so kasse okay
wir nicht so nachrichten problem du erst
mal ich kann als collage seit wann ist
dass wir für die kriege dann ab 31 23
[Gelächter]
vorstellbar ist ja ekelhaft
das wird was ich meine mit 85 hingesetzt
hat gesagt dass mitglieder auf markt wir
brauchen dafür schmecken so
vorstandsetage von erkläre ich welche
mag auch immer das ist wir brauchen aus
kassel chips die nach physisch mengen
alle lachen sich so eine abo unsere
kunden trikots er und dann so einer so
gehasst aber richtig verarschen lassen
april heftig und mehr sein und dann
kommt das wasser das schmeckt so als
würde jemand so richtig intensiv sport
machen land und 20 minuten spielen und
dann liegt jemand seine stirn ab wie das
schmeckt man am 8
so lecker aus max stören füßen des teams
richtung liebst du noch dafür was vorhin
schon jesus christus sein sollte dann
alle jesus fans der nächsten jahr dieses
gekümmert von jesus fällen sonst könnt
ihr so einen christen leute darüber
geredet dass uns war es hier deswegen
sei es mal kurz kann sich kurz
entspannen ich habe die perfekte
abkühlung für dich bester alba hat jetzt
aber auch nur dann hab ich mal eine
andere person die gemeinde das ist
komplett ast und davon kotzen muss ja
nicht immer gesagt
das belebt sie kamen operativ überhaupt
guck mal ein close-up von dieser
wunderbaren substanz ja super mysteriös
aus ich hab das ja selber gekauft ich
bin ja selbst schuld so das ist mir
nicht sagen müssen das ist längst aber
du warst und die sind wirklich die
schlimmsten sachen außer eine sache die
hast du gestrichen
genauso die hassliebe natürlich was
natürlich soll auch krank einfach
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend aber trieben nicht alles mit
was haben das riecht auch schon so das
ist wie erzählte jemand joghurt in den
mund genommen und dann so mit spucke
fahrer also diese ist für mich wenn ich
das trink ich denke ich trink so stocker
großen schluck spucke an der stelle
neben kurz auf konzentrieren wie lecker
diese menschliche spucke schmeckt wenn
man sie munter aber weiß was die spucke
speed und deswegen macht mir das gar
[Musik]
nicht so gut da
ganz kurz zum beispiel feine sache also
wenn jetzt tatsächlich brad pitt eines
tages klingeln würde da reinkommen würde
und zu sagen oder soja auch hat er wird
nicht sagen da wird ja einfach so in den
mund spucken wird erstens oder
wirtschaft das wollte ja nur wissen sagt
er noch dass videos das ist der kick
beta kann ohne wird sich ja immer
gemocht haben mit deiner beschreiben das
aus gestemmt wurde wird so schaffen wir
nicht erkenntlich gemacht ich hasse
deshalb schwer weil ich niemanden habe
dessen spucke ich halt so trinken würde
[Musik]
miss projekts leute haben wir ein
comeback zum ersten mal wieder soweit
ich weiß haben wir eine zutat mehrmals
vorkommt sollte ich meine interessiert
und zwar und gar nicht so kam tochter
doch muss man verstehen weil du bist
ganz so groß ich krieg das dazwischen
das kann man nicht bauen aber okay aber
es ist ganz schön und hässlich mainz ist
meist es so eine originale missgeburt
jetzt kommen
diebesgut sagen doch bis 21 grad bis zu
besitzen
sie hat jüngst wieder aus dem
menschliche roten heck wie sie in eine
wohnhaus muss ich mal zum arzt gedacht
das ist richtig aber ehrlich mit einer
rundfahrt haben dass der echte problem
also vom prinzip her so kanal ok nicht
ganz so
[Musik]
ich komme mal spricht man das redet das
mercatura wäsche auf wertersatz für
welche ist dass von dieser folge leute
ich habe auf jeden fall aggressiv kotzen
müssen
juni ist herrscher verlinkt und jetzt
gleich in der intensivstation im
krankenhaus weiß auch dabei kommt bevor
sie an einer tomaten vergiftung stürzten
dann ihr seid in den nächsten fünf oder
auch öfter damit deuten mehrmals nicht
wirken und ihre mutter trafen sich noch
eine folge von was geht völlig neue
folge mit mir oder anderen menschen
tipps gerne ab falls ihr keine erklärten
dinge haben wollt in einem video